[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نشا القارئ هشام الشبيهي في مدينه سلا
المغربيه قرب العاصمه الرباط وفي كتاتيبها
القرانيه شق بدايته في عالم الحفظ
والتلاوه بدا الحفظه في الخامسه عشر من
العمر وهو سن متاخر نسبيا قياسا باقرنه من
الحفاظ ومع ذلك اظهر نبوغا جعل كبار
القراء المغاربه يشجعونه على تلقي علوم
القران واتقان احكامه وتعلم فنونه وهو ما
تم له فكان موهوبا في القراءه بصيغه
المغربيه التي تعتمد المقامات او الطلوع
الاندلسيه شارك في المحافل والسهرات
المغربيه لاحياء القران الكريم وسجل اسمه
ضمن القراء النوابغ المشهود لهم بجمال
الصوت وحسن الاداء لما كنت صغير لم اكن
اهتم كثيرا بالقران الكريم كنت يعني الحمد
لله انا كبرت في اسره محافظه اسره متدينه
كنت اعشق القران لكن لم اكن لم يكن عندي
اهتمام عشاء لحفظ القران الكريم
لكن بعد ما صار عمري 15 سنه 16 سنه بدا
ميولي
يميل الى القران الكريم
فبجانبي اني كنت ادرس في المدارس الحكوميه
فتوجهت الى الكتاتيب القرانيه لحفظ القران
الكريم
لتعلم القراءه الصحيحه
فالتحقت بكتاب الشيخ محمد السحابي بمدينه
سلا وهناك درست القران الكريم وتعلمت على
يده القراءه الصحيحه
فكانت هذا كان هذا هو المشوار الاول
لانطلاقه في القران الكريم وكنت اهتم
كثيرا بالقران الكريم
وكنت تقريبا يوميا استدعى للقاءات
ولمناسبات لترتيل القران الكريم
لكن لما
اشتد العود
اردت ان اتوجه الى الامامه لكن لم اوفق في
ذلك لان طبيعه
تربيه التي تربيت فيها لم تكن تميل الى ان
على الامامه والى
اشتغال في بيت الله
اينعم كنت يعني تقريبا سنوات عديده تقريبا
اكثر من 15 سنه وانا قارئ في مساجد مدينه
سلا ليوم الجمعه
لكن
لكي اكون اماما لم لم اتوجه هذا التوجه
ولم تكن لي رغبه لكي يعني
للامامه في المساجد كان اهتمامي وكان
تاثيري تاثري جدا جدا جدا بالقارئ محمد
صديق المنشاوي
هذا كان كان هو يعني
المثل الاعلى اليه من في قضيه الطريقه
الشرقيه وبحكم على انني كبرت في المغرب
وللمغرب طريقته خاصه كنت كذلك مولعا
بالطريقه المغربيه وكان الشيخ
بن موسى سيدي عبد الرحمن بن موسى رحمه
الله عليه كان من الناس الذين شدوا
انتباهي وشدوا حنيني لهذه القراءه وكنت
اعشق ان استمع اليه والتقيت به رحمه الله
عليه في اواخر ايامه
واخذت منه
اصول القراءه المغربيه وقرات عليه
واستمع الي وصحح لي
وقيم قراءتي من الناحيه
الفنيه قراءه قضيه الترتيل كيف يعني
كيف يمكن للقارئ ان يقرا بطريقه المغربيه
اما بالنسبه لقواعد القران الكريم قواعد
التجويد
بالنسبه للقراءه الصحيحه فهذا تعلمته على
يد الشيخ محمد الصحابي
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله
[موسيقى]
ولتم ما قدمت لغد
يتقوا الله
واتقوا الله
[موسيقى]
خبير
بما تعملون
[موسيقى]
ولا تكونوا
كالذين نسوا الله
فان
سى اوسهم
اولئك هم الفاسقون
[موسيقى]
لا يستوي
اصحاب
النمر واصحاب الجنه
الجنه هم
[موسيقى]
لو انزلنا هذا القران على جبل
لرايته
خاشعا
متصدعا من خشيه
الله وتلك الامثال نضربها
للناس
لعلهم يتفكرون
[موسيقى]
هو الله الذي
لا اله
الا هو
عالم الغيب والشهاده
هو الرحمن الرحيم
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
هو الله الذي
لا اله
[موسيقى]
القدوس السلام
المؤمن الجبار المتكبر
سبحان الله
عما يشركون
[موسيقى]
هو الله
الخالق البارئ المصور
لول
ا الحسنى
يسبح له ما في السماوات وال
[موسيقى]
ارض وهو العزيز الحكيم
امنت بالله وحده
لا اله الا الله
محمد
رسول الله ام
ن
بالله
في سنه اواخر سنه
بعد ما تزوجت
جئت على هولندا
بتجمع عائلي
بدات حياتي وكانت بدايه صعبه جدا
لانني انتقلت من عالم
فيه حب للقران في حب للامداح في حب للاسر
للاسره في حب للاصدقاء وجيت الى العالم لا
اعرف فيه احدا الا زوجتي
وابواها واخواتها
فكانت البدايه بدايه صعبه
اخذني
حماي الى المسجد الموجود في المدينه التي
رحت اليها وهي مدينه دنبوص في جنوب هولندا
وعرفني على
مسؤولين المسجد هناك وكانت اول قدومه
باسبوع قبل بدايه رمضان
وكان الامام هناك تعرف عليه
فكانت بدايه موفقه معه بان ساعدته في
تراويح
رمضان في تلك السنه وكان اقبالا
للمصلين باقبال بطريقه
رهيبه
لانهم سمعوا صوت جديد سمعوا انسان جديد
جاء الى هولندا وتعرفوا علي من طريق عن
طريق حماي فكانت لقاء حميمي وكان كان يعني
كل الاهتمام الحمد لله من هؤلاء الاخوه
نشكرهم من هذا المنبر على تلك الحفاوه
التي قدموها الي
لكن بعد ذلك طلب مني كي يعني امسك المسجد
واكون اماما هناك في ذلك المسجد لكن لم
ارض بذلك لانني لا اريد ان اكون يعني
ارتبط بالامامه
فكنت بس مساعدا لهم في هذه
الايام العصيبه او في الاوقات التي لا
يكون امام موجود او في عدم عدم وجود
الايمان فاساعدهم في الخطاب في الدروس في
المواعيد في القراءه القران في الصلاه الى
غير ذلك
فكانت هذه الرحله من سنه 98
قل بدايه تسعه وتسعين الى الالفين 2006
كانت اموري شويه صعب صعبه يعني في البدايه
فكان
لم اوفق في ان اجد الطريقه الصحيح الذي
كنت ارسمه لكي اشق طريقي هنا في هولندا
فقررت بعد ذلك الى الهجره الى الامارات
العربيه المتحده
طلبا من
كانت الدعوه من اصدقائي كانوا ائمه هناك
في في العين وفي ابوظبي
فرحتوا زياره عندهم فاخذوني الى وزاره
الاوقاف
وكان المسؤول هناك على الاذان الموحد
فقالوا له هذا الشيخ يعني يحسن الاذان
اذان الشرقي ويحسن اذان مكه
فجربه فقال لاذن فاذنت فقال لي انت الحين
موظف عندنا هنا
فكانت هناك الانطلاقه سبحان الله العظيم
سنتين مرت سنه في ابوظبي فكنت مؤذنا في
الاذان الموحد هناك وسنه في العين لكن بعد
ذلك
لم يستقر الحال فرجعت الى هولندا
بعد رجوع الى هولندا قررت ان ابدا دراسه
جديده
لكي اشق طريقي في المستقبل الذي كنت احلم
به
فدرست
علم التربيه
تقريبا اربع سنوات بعد ذلك اخذت الدبلوم
اجازته
ثم اشتغلت في هذا الحقل
بعد ثلاث سنوات
طورت شيئا من من
التعليم فعملت تخصص
في
المشاكل الاسريه
في الطلاق وفي حمايه الطفوله
فدرست سنه كامله في هذا التخصص والحمد لله
يعني
توفقت فيه ومن هناك وانا اشتغل الى الى
يومنا هذا يعني اشتغل في هذا الحقل
والحمد لله
البذره التي وضعتها الان وانني اساعد
الاسر العربيه النازحه من سوريا
في هذا المجال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التحق القارئ هشام الشبيهي للعيش في
هولندا نهايه التسعينيات وفي عالمه الجديد
اتقن اللغه الهولنديه دون انقطاعه عن لقاء
كبار القره مساهما بدوره كامما وقارئ
اشتهر لدى الجليات المسلمه في عديد
الانشطه الاجتماعيه وبرز في وظيفته
الجديده كموجه اسري في حمايه الطفوله
اضافه الى امامته المصلين في عدد من
المساجد واحيائه للمناسبات الدينيه التي
تقيمها الجاليه المسلمه في بلده الجديد
بالنسبه
للمشاركات القرانيه يعني مشاركه كثيره في
داخل هولندا وفي خارج هولندا مثلا في
فرنسا او في بلجيكا او في المانيا استدعى
كثيرا الى المساجد
للمشاركه في مثلا في ندوات او في ايام
مثلا ترفيهيه او ايام دراسيه
لقراءه القران ولاعطاء بعض الدروس
والمحاضرات
كذلك
المسابقه شاركت في مسابقه وحيده في حياتي
هي لما كان عند عمري 19 سنه
شاركت في المسابقه الدوليه للقران الكريم
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه في نسختها
الخامسه اهتمام بالقراءه كان
اول اولا قبل ان اتكلم على هذا الموضوع
اريد ان الفت النظر الى شيء مهم هو انه
منحه من الله سبحانه وتعالى ورحمه من الله
سبحانه وتعالى وعطاء من الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وهبني الله سبحانه وتعالى ملكه في القراءه
وفي
تذوق
الاصوات وتذوق الالحان
وهذه كان عندي يعني ميول اليها من صغري
لكن لم اكتشف يعني لم اطورها حتى صار عمري
16 سنه بدات بدات تتعلم هذه الاشياء وبدات
يعني اتذوق القراءه الشرقيه وكانت تجذبني
كثيرا
وتاخذ قلبي خصوصا في قراءه القران لما
اتكلم على الشيخ المنشاوي كان يشدني شدا
كبيرا
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
يا عبادي
لا خوف
عليكم اليوم
ولا تم تحزن
وا الذين
[موسيقى]
ادخلوا
الجنه
انتم واعزواجكم
[موسيقى]
ادخلوا الجنه
انتم
وازواجكم تحض
[موسيقى]
رون
يطاف
عليهم بصحاف
من ذهب
واك
وا
وفيها ما تشتهيه
لانفسوا وتلذ لع
يون
انتم
خالد
[موسيقى]
وتلك
الجنه
[موسيقى]
تُرثتموها بما
كنتم تعملون
[موسيقى]
لكم فيها فاكهه
كثيره منها
المجرمين
[موسيقى]
خالد
لا يفتر
[موسيقى]
عنهم المبلسون
ووظا
وما
ظلمناهم ولكن
كانوا
الضال
ونادا يا مالك
ليقطع علينا
ربك قال
انكم ما
[موسيقى]
قد جئناكم
للحق ولكن
انا اكثر
كم
لحقك كاره
[موسيقى]
صدق الله العظيم
لو تكلمنا بكل صراحه فانها نظره الدون
من اكثر
المقيمين هنا في هولندا او في اوروبا
لانهم يظنون على ان القارئ او الحامل
لكتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى من ابخس الناس
ومن ارخص الناس
لكن انا لا اعم الكلام على كل الجاليه
المسلمه الموجوده هنا في ناس التي تحترم
وتحب وتجل القارئ وتجل حفظت كتاب الله
سبحانه وتعالى لكن الاغلبيه
يعني لا يقدسون القارئ كما يقدس في البلاد
الاسلاميه
احتراما لكلام الله واحتراما
للمكان التي وضع فيها لان كما تعلمون كما
جاء في الحديث على ان يوم القيامه يقال
للقارئ اقرا ورقه ورتل كما كنت ترتل في
الدنيا فان منزلتك عند اخر ايه تقراها فان
كان هذا مقام الله سبحانه وتعالى الذي
يعطيه لعباده القراء او الحفاظ
فان هذا المقام
قد بخس القارئ فيه بين ظهرانين الجاليه
الاسلاميه في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات